plus trying to care about everyone
cheapens the care for the ones you deem
worthy of your care yeah i i
i wrote a chapter in my book called um
managing your f's um and um i see it as
a limited resource i mean you only have
so much energy in the data you know to
dispense for things that matter so why
would you dispense it on things that
don't matter or don't have an roi or
don't improve your life or don't you
know connect you with better people and
all that sort of stuff it's like people
are constantly trying to steal your
attention and your time with their
[ __ ] with you know manufactured
indignation in the media about some
[ __ ] disease that kills almost nobody
or some something that's happening in a
part of the world you know
it's gonna have no bearing on you
whatsoever right right right yeah
they're always trying to suck you into
these narratives but it but it's like
you know um actually
that kind of brings me to the idea of
perimeters because i think in one of
your books you
you talk about drawing a perimeter you
know like
and defining us versus them and um you
know i do that with different levels of
perimeters like i might have a perimeter
you know amongst the five people you
know that are closest to me like my
family you know the people that love my
kid you know you know sort of thing then
you've got your friends and you've got
your community then you've got you know
sort of thing and it's like a concentric
set of rings that um you know kind of go
out in a
a tree and the further the rings out the
fewer [ __ ] you give on what happens you
know like in that ring and the
definition of us versus them is
obviously more us here and more them you
know further out um can you talk a
little bit about that perimeter and the
thinking you know behind that and why
you talked about that in your book
well i think it's foundational to what
men do in the world uh fundamentally i
mean and this is i went back into this
again it started in the way of men
there's a chapter called the perimeter
and then uh you know i revisited that in
fire in the dark recently because that
has to do with what men do in every
sense
is that you know you go into an area in
almost a military sense and you
establish a space a safe space
you know and you know not from for your
feelings or whatever but uh you know you
you secure a space
and you take control that space and then
everything outside of that space is
beyond your control
and everything outside of that is
chaotic
and what men really do is they create
order in the midst of chaos because the
world is chaotic and they're trying to
create a place of order and so then you
know everything that's within your
perimeter is everything that you really
care about and you want to protect and
and
and that's
you know everything outside of it is you
know them you know like it's it's the
unknown
and uh that's i think just a really
important concept in terms of what men
do in the world is that we want to
create order from chaos and it happens
at every level of things
um as far as like other perimeters like
socially and things like that like you
were talking about
it's
you know obvi obviously yeah you have
your your closest group of people and it
expands outward and you know that
i love the metaphor of that's why i talk
about fire and dark there's a metaphor
of fire
and that's what we've always been around
is this campfire and it closes the
campfire you can see things and you can
understand things and you know what's
there and who's there and everybody
around it is important and then it gets
less and less light
as it goes further further out
and uh you know also i think in the way
men talked about uh perimeters in terms
of socially you know in terms of
dunbar's number which you could really
care about like 150 people
and uh and also if you if you look at
like the military when people interview
the military like the people the guys
like platoon or his you know fire team
or whatever are the people who he will
care about most and then like as you get
to bigger units they're like that's just
guys you know that there's just guys out
there that are technically on our team
uh but uh you know we keep people people
are tribal so you know people who are
closest into their tribe or the people
that they care about most and that's
natural
and again it's this is the way that
humans operate
and uh we're told that it's not you know
that it's that we're supposed to care
about everything and everyone in the
world but we can't we're like physically
incapable of doing that and and as i
think your reader just said
um you know to say that you do you know
if you love everyone you do you love no
one you know it cheapens the entire uh
word uh you know if you really care
about someone you care about them to the
exclusion of others you know they care
about them more
yeah actually that kind of ties into the
notion of the empire of nothing right
because they want you to care about this
like empire which is essentially nothing
can you talk a little bit about the
empire of nothing concept
yeah i mean i think the easiest way you
know a lot of readers might be younger
but uh
the never-ending story is a really good
way and i didn't think of this when i
wrote it but i've used it many times
afterward
is that
this idea that there's nothing really
means anything
the difference is um
what was that narnia the line the
wichita wardrobe or is that something
else no it's actually called the
neverending story movie where they
basically and they actually fight
nothing basically it's a child it's a
children's story
and you know like basically it's the
absence of dreams and the absence of
identity is coming and it's kind of just
destroying everything around it and i
think that's what's happening with you
know globalism and like this monoculture
that we have is is that you know all
these things that were very intensely
meaningful to people
they kind of want to take that away
and whether it's you know religion or
you know racial groups or ethnic groups
or like any of these things they want to
take that away and replace that with
well we are the source of what you care
about you know whatever's trending on
twitter is what you care about now
and so it's just there's no fixed point
and that's why i talk about it as being
an empire of nothing like for you know
for like a christian like there's the
bible is like the fixed point like
everything is less holy as you get out
from there
and uh for any of us uh in any of us who
have any kind of moral center whatever
that is
you know we have a very specific
idea of what's right and wrong and what
we care about and as you get further and
further away from that things become
more profane
and so the you know the empire nothing i
think is just this idea that they're
eroding culture
on every level and uh identity
you know i'm at this or i'm a that where
your identities are like in in flux and
they're consumeristic identities like i
buy things and i i listen to this band
and therefore i have an identity rather
than like i have this family that i'm
tied to and and uh this long lineage of
people
uh so it's just an erasure of culture is
what i
think about and replacing with
consumerism hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you